the Stoics epictetus included in
particular and what we would call a
fully developed theory of human nature
sometimes we call this a philosophical
anthropology they also had what we would
call a philosophy of action and
philosophy the action is dealing with
issues such as the relationship between
freedom and Turman ism how it is that
we're actually able to choose to do
things make ourselves do things how it
is that human beings are connected with
the world are we just our actions or our
choices caused by things outside of our
control or do they they lie within our
control these are all the sorts of
things that Epictetus is is deeply
concerned with and one of the things
you're going to see him talking about
over and over and over again in this
work is what he's calling the the ruling
faculty or sometimes called the rational
faculty he also talks about our Faculty
of choice sometimes use of the words
moral purpose in the translation as I've
mentioned before Faculty of choice and
moral purpose both translate the Greek
proi raíces and I'll talk a little bit
about what that term means in a moment
and oftentimes we think of this as the
will when we talk about a person as
having free will what we typically mean
is that that person is able to determine
themselves that is they are able to make
choices between different alternatives
freely they're also able to take a sort
of reflexive position upon their own
choices they if it's possible for you to
to think that your choices were wrong or
to choose not to make the same choice
again or to make a good choice and then
to say I need to keep making this choice
over and over again until it becomes a
habit through perseveringly willing that
choice that is a
kind of freedom so epic for epictetus
all of these are really coming down to
the same thing there are there different
ways of looking at the same basic
phenomenon or idea we're going to look
at the text in just a moment I do want
to talk a little bit about this notion
of Pride racist know that this Greek
word pride racists can be translated as
preference as well without deforming it
too much yeah and if you think about
what happens when you prefer one thing
to another or you prioritize this is
another way of thinking about when you
prioritize you say that this matters
more and this matters less and how do
you know that that's actually the case
well if you can't have both of them and
you have to sacrifice one of them the
one that's actually more valuable is the
priority and the other one has a lower
priority or the top one is your highest
preference and the other one is your
lower preference now if you think about
what you're doing when you're making
decisions when you're choosing how to
respond to things when you're deciding
about what you're going to do with the
resources that you have at your capacity
which include your ability to think your
ability to choose a lot of that can be
understood in terms of preference
because think about thinking for a
moment now when I say to that and say
that to you right now hopefully you are
indeed thinking about thinking but you
might also be thinking about when is he
gonna get to the point how long is this
video I've got you know something boring
laying it on the stove you know there's
noise outside you know you could be
thinking about a lot of different things
if you were allowing yourself to be
distracted that's in a certain way kind
of a choice isn't it and Epictetus would
be willing to say that's a preference
now you can understand preference is
what you do in an individual
circumstance within a particular
situation and you can understand it in
the more global sense as pervading your
whole narrative or at least a portion of
the narrative
of your life your relationships with
other people how it is that you
characteristically engage with the rest
of the world or reflect upon yourself
see we can understand this as not just
being some sort of tool or you know
capacity that we have but is really
being the fabric of who we are what's
really interesting about it is that this
is something that we can develop further
along
bit by bit by bit we can also make it
worse over time if we make the wrong
choices and we do that over the course
of our life by the time that we get to
the end of our life we may regret the
kind of people that we've turned out to
be but we're not going to be able to
change it so you notice I've got this
arrow here this reflexivity that's our
capacity to actually change ourselves
and that's our freedom it's a little bit
different than the freedom to you know
pick Coke or Pepsi or RC or not to drink
coke at all the freedom to think about
what kind of person do I want to be how
do I want to mold this thing that I am
that I barely understand into something
that is going to be happier there is
going to be less conflict with other
people or is not going to be so anxious
or will you know have some some idea
about what I'm supposed to be doing here
what is the point of human life that's a
higher degree of freedom and forever
Tunis it takes place within what we call
determinism where things determine each
other we are you might say this is an
Aristotelian term now the stoic term
self moving things we make choices about
what we're going to do with what we are
and in those form who we are over time
let's look at the text there's gonna be
a couple main ideas that will come up
you notice I've got some other stuff on
the board I don't have everything
written on the board because I don't
want to super clutter it everything that
we'll talk about but but I'll note those
in turn
so again you know if we begin the
discourse is where they start chapter
one is titled of the things which your
inner power and not in our power but he
doesn't begin by talking about those he
begins by talking about faculties and
one is a faculty a faculty is a sort of
Nexus of ability you can call it within
you so if you think about your senses
for example your sense of sight it's not
something that changes from moment to
moment insofar as it's the sense the
things that you're seeing change from
moment to moment as you're scanning
around the room but that Faculty of
sight that resides in your eyeballs and
I suppose in the optic nerve and your
mental processing in your brain and all
those sorts of things that remains the
same over time otherwise you wouldn't be
able to recognize what you're seeing
would you and we have other faculties as
well I can talk about my Faculty of
locomotion going back and forth in place
right I have these amazing tools that
can do anything with all sorts of other
tools Aristotle called the hand the tool
of tools and the Stoics would agree with
that it's that which we grasp with you
notice that a lot of their conceptual
terminology is actually taken from hand
language so we have fantasies some of
them are our faculties from say
digestion or respiration and we need
those but most important are the
faculties that compose what we would
call our mind or our soul or our
personality so he says of all these
faculties you'll not find one which is
capable of contemplating itself why does
that matter so what if sight can't see
itself so what if digestion can't you
know think about whether it's digesting
well or anything like that he gets a few
other examples the grammatic art you
know the art of speaking a language now
you can use language to talk about
language as a matter of fact they
grammar
as a linguistic tool that reflects upon
the language that it's about but the the
Faculty of grammar the the language
processing parts of your brain if you
want to think about it that way are not
reflexive in the same way that what he's
talking about here is music music can
judge about melody it can judge whether
certain things are harmonious or
discordant it can you know music theory
is developed quite a bit it can tell you
if you want to produce this kind of
psychological effect play this kind of
music but music can't reflect upon
itself so insofar as we have some
faculty developed we're not using that
to reflect upon the nature of human
being
we're just reflecting on the the object
that we're dealing with so he says does
either these contemplate it's off by no
means but when you must write something
to your friend grammar will tell you
what words to use you know if you want
to actually communicate with other
people it's awfully handy to have the
linguistic faculty isn't it and if you
want to play with music that's awfully
handy for it as well if you don't
develop the skill that you need you know
for instance I I used to play the bass
guitar again if you handed it to me
right now I probably wouldn't be very
good at cuz I haven't played one for
over 15 years I do have a banjo and I
can play some things on that out of the
great level Ocilla day but you know to
some degree and that's because I
developed that but that that doesn't
reflect upon itself the way the ruling
faculty does so he says whether you
should sing at the present time and play
on the lute or do neither music won't
tell you that whether you should be
looking at this thing or eating this
thing your senses won't actually tell
you that whether you should say this or
that grammar will tell you well if you
want to communicate in this way this is
what you should say
but grammar won't actually tell you it
would be good for you to do that that's
up to some other part of ourselves that
has to think about what's really good or
bad
appropriate inappropriate where our
duties lie
where are you know our we have a lot of
freedom or latitude to do one thing or
another that's not up to those faculties
so you go domine says which faculty will
tell you about that well it's the
rational faculty the ruling part in in
stoic anthropology we have parts to
ourselves and how do you want to
understand those parts it all depends on
you know how you want to parse it out
but it's not like say for example Plato
with his three parts of the soul one
part of being the rational part and then
there being this thematic part and on
the appetites instead it's really the
rational part and pretty much everything
else another thing to keep in mind as
well is that the Stoics when it comes
down to it are actually materialist so
they don't think that soul is something
totally independent of body they think
that soul is something that comes out of
a particular configuration of the body
or perhaps it's composed of certain
bodily elements that are visible but can
be understood so if you want to think of
this as part of our brain Epictetus
really wouldn't have a fundamental
problem with you doing that today
there's a there's a capacity that we
have for figuring out what we ought to
do with other things the senses for
example our bodily parts for deciding
whether things are good for us or bad
for us we're also able to take a
position like that on our thoughts and
opinions on our emotions our desires and
aversions and we'll get to that in just
a moment I must really want to stress
this reflexivity though he says the
rational faculty is the only faculty we
have received which examines itself
which looks at what it is it's only
reason that can tell us
what reason is whether it's working
right how it should be trained what it
takes to develop it says what power it
has what is the value of its gift and it
examines all the other faculties it is
this faculty which is also capable and
he brings up another term here of
judging of appearances things that are
coming to us from the outside whenever
we're doing that we're getting something
say through our senses but then we have
to process it we have to figure out
what's what's going on
how should I interpret that information
that's coming to me you know that's part
of why when we watch TV or you know
nowadays most of us watch it on our
computers or our phones or tablets we
don't see an image of somebody say
shooting a gun at us and immediately run
out of the room because our senses are
telling us hey there's there's a
gunfight going on you know and our I
suppose our native instinct for
self-preservation to probably say you
better get down but our ruling faculty
says not enough don't worry about that
we're just we're watching that for
entertainment right now or it's just
background or that's not a real thing
that's what our capacity for word for
thinking allows us so let's go on and
look at a few other sections as well
where he's saying some very important
things let's look at section 2 chapter 2
of the first book he talks about the
rational and the irrational now we've
talked about the rational part but the
rational part can get screwed up it can
go astray if it does that it's doing
things in an irrational manner right
when we say that somebody is being
irrational we mean that they're going
against reason now this brings up a
really interesting point if everybody
has this rational part how are people
able to be irrational does it mean that
that part just like goes
commission like for example when I when
I go into a rage I'm angry you know I I
see red you know whatever that means
I've never actually seen red you know
blood before my eyes or something like
that but I know what it's like to be
angry and to say stupid things that you
regret later on because you're so
overcome by that emotion that it feels
like the emotion turns off the part of
your brain that would be counseling you
and saying wait a second you you like
this person if you see those sorts of
things to them you're going to damage
your relationship perhaps you know
irrevocably because man if somebody was
going to say that sort of stuff to me I
sure wouldn't forgive them I wouldn't
want to do anything with them after that
anger feels like it's like it does that
sometimes doesn't it at least for some
of us but epictetus would say no you
know what's really going on there that's
not something that's totally separate
from this rational part the person is
thinking when they're angry for the
Stoics emotions desires aversions they
correspond the thoughts to opinions to
judgments about things when I get angry
the Stoics would say what I'm actually
thinking is I have been wronged and I've
been wronged by that person over there
and there that's one complex of thoughts
and along with that goes a feeling right
and then the other complex of thoughts
that goes along with it is I shouldn't
take that I should get revenge on them I
should make them suffer in return like
I'm feeling pain right now that's
another set of thoughts but along with
it is going a desire I want them to feel
hurt some aversion I don't want to have
anything to do with that some other
emotions you know it may grieve me that
I'm hurting them in the process but at
the same time I'm taking a sort of
delight in it you know Homer says anger
is sweeter than honey and the ancient
Greeks seem to think that was a pretty
apt description well all of that
actually affects our ruling part our
rational
hurt the person who's who's allowing
themselves to be angry or the person who
is greedy for example and is able to
tell themselves over and over again what
I'm doing really isn't that bad I'm not
really harming myself and I'm just
taking stuff from other people they
probably had it coming to them anyway if
they don't want me to you know take
advantage of them well they should just
be smarter these are thoughts these are
not just random individual thoughts
these are thought processes that become
part of the fabric of who a person is so
Epictetus will tell us in another
chapter later on in the work the ruling
faculty the rational Faculty of a bad
person is not to be trusted
because what they've done is they've
damaged it it's sort of like imagine if
you had a computer and you downloaded
all sorts of stuff indiscriminately from
the internet onto it even if you have a
Mac you're gonna get some malware and
what does that now we're gonna do some
of the malware is going to like let
people snoop on what you're typing and
maybe steal your credit card not good
other malware might be you know crashing
your system or using your system to
replicate stuff that it's sending out to
other people it gets into your email
file you've probably all had some
relative who's not careful with what
they click on and set you something that
had a virus at one time or another some
other kind of malware and some malware
is so sophisticated that what it does is
it pops up and it says you have malware
on your system we've detected it click
here for a full scan and then you click
there and there were actually wasn't
anything on your system but you click
there and now all the other stuff comes
in you can think of what's going on in
in the cases of people who don't take
care of their ruling faculty and allow
it to be determined by appearances by
things that are outside of our control
is downloading a bunch of malware it
makes you vulnerable to manipulation to
coercion
Epictetus is case you would say it makes
you vulnerable to sadness to trouble to
being affected by things that are coming
from outside of your control things that
other people or natural events or fate
has control over but you don't so going
back to this issue of the rational
irrational
he says the rational and the irrational
appear such in a different way to
different persons just as the good and
the bad the profitable and the
unprofitable for this reason we need
discipline we need some training in
order to learn how to adapt our
preconception I should put that term
here this is something that we have
we've talked about this these
preconceptions these general ideas how
do we adapt these to external things to
appearances how do we adapt our notion
of good which is rather vague to the
things that were encountering so we
don't screw it up and think that bad
things are actually good a properly
functioning rational ruling part is
going to make those kinds of decisions
well because it has some sort of guide
some sort of rule so he says in order to
determine the rational and the
irrational we use not only the external
things but we also consider what's
appropriate to each person here he has a
very funny example of somebody who you
know has to hold a chamber pot for
another person a chamber pot is
literally a pot to piss him it's you
know the the toilets before toilets
existed and you know so holding a
chamber pot is a pretty low thing to do
and a lot of people would say that's not
for me you know you keep your money I'm
going to do something else I'm gonna
find another job and then Pam would be
like an example of a chamber pot right
that would be the modern equivalent so
he says you know some people will say
that it's consistent with reason to hold
the chamber pot for
and to look to this only but if he
doesn't hold it he's gonna receive
stripes meaning he's gonna get whipped
and will not receive his food but if he
shall hold the pot he won't suffer
anything hard or disagreeable to another
person not only does the holding of a
chamber pot appear intolerable but it's
also intolerable for him to allow
another to do this for office for him
and Epictetus says so if you ask me
should you hold the chamber pot or not I
can't say it that's up to you and when I
say it's up to you I don't mean just go
with your gut or anything like that you
seriously need to think about where your
priorities lie the priorities that
you've established for yourself because
those are going to determine how you
take in and interpret information and
how you make choices about these things
in the world that we have to engage in
including other people including their
demands upon us including what they
offer to us so as your rational faculty
is well ordered you're going to be a
rational person if you're rational
faculty is disordered even though you
have a rational faculty it's going to
generate irrationality and that's gonna
trickle down into your thoughts and your
opinions and your emotions you may let
your emotions run the show which for a
stoic is a very bad idea your desires
and aversions
are gonna be skewed to all sorts of
things that you don't have any control
over and if you do that as he says
what does desire want to enjoy the good
that it desires desire it means seeing
something is it good and if I see
something is it good I naturally want to
extend towards it
aversion is a function of seeing
something as a bad thing it's up there's
a thought that goes along with it an
opinion that's a bad thing
I want to avoid it if you desire things
that you don't have any control over or
very little control you're probably
going to be unhappy because the the
external world is not set up to make you
happy it's set up to do what it does
same thing if you are averse to things
that are beyond your control
you're going to be unhappy he has the
example for example
his example for example see I wish I
hadn't said then I've got an aversion to
saying stupid things but apparently I
have very very little control of that he
has this example of going to the baths
and the Greeks had public baths and it's
not really going to the public swimming
pool if you've ever gone to the public
swimming pool it's kind of fun but it's
not really a treat because it'd be great
if it wasn't for all the other people
that are there and some of them are fun
but you know there's always going to be
some guy who's playing as music too loud
or somebody who's like eating some
really stinky food or somebody who's
shouting at their children there's give
me some children running around and you
know engaging in all sorts of craziness
somebody will probably come here near to
drowning you can do a run through all
sorts of things you know that's not to
mention what people actually do in the
pool I don't need to talk about that now
if you are averse to that sort of thing
you probably shouldn't choose to go to
the public pool right is what what the
the ruling faculty would tell us because
those sort of things whether the public
pool experience is the way that you
imagine it really lies outside of your
control and that is our choice whether
we steer our desires and our versions in
certain ways we have some choice about
modifying those modifying our mindset
changing over time the kind of viewpoint
that we have and becoming thereby more
rational let's look at in another
section this from book 2 chapter 17 when
we've looked at already how we must
adapt adapt preconceptions to particular
cases he says who among us does not
speak of good and bad useful and not
useful for who among us is not a
preconception of these things is it then
a distinct imperfect preconception
probably not so one of the things that
we want to do if we want this ruling
faculty to be in good shape if we want
it to genuinely be free and not being
determined by all this other stuff over
here we want to find some sort of
discipline or a rule
will allow us to adapt these things
properly and he says if you adapt prompt
if you properly adapt your
preconceptions you're not going to be
unhappy you're not going to be hindered
yeah that's what I wanted to get from
that one now he's got another discussion
in book 3 chapter 3 he says that the
material for the wise and the good
person is our ruling faculty that's what
we should be most concerned with now
that's not the case for most of us most
of us are actually using a ruling
faculty not to look at itself you know
I'm gonna erase the reflexivity here but
instead to sort of look at all the other
things outside of our control including
our own body which isn't really fully in
our control but definitely external
things like property and possessions
other people and instead of sort of
withdrawing our desires and aversions
from those things and occupying yourself
with getting our our ourselves on track
with actually developing this part of
ourselves out of the morass that it's
typically in we scatter and distract
ourselves with all of these things over
here which then make us worse over here
it takes you can think of this as sort
of like developing a muscle the ability
to look at yourself to come to good
judgements about your own faculty to
stick to resolutions that you make for
example that's something that requires
dedication that requires some practice
so he says the good person the person is
going to live a good life has to occupy
themselves mostly over here the body is
the material for the physician or the
trainer that doesn't mean that you don't
care about your body you don't try to be
healthy we've already talked about that
right but the body is not really what
you
are so much and you don't have so much
control over it land is a matter for the
husband men or the farmer if you
actually have land let it out to your
farmer don't think about it let them
give let them have the worries let those
other people you know concern their
ruling parts with making sure that your
land is tilled well and you could say
the same thing about other things
doesn't it be land it could be your car
you know know if you like you know doing
your own work on your car
go ahead otherwise leave it to the
mechanic and don't worry about it
because that's outside of your control
you do have a choice whether you go to a
mechanic who screws you over or not or a
mechanic who's got a good reputation you
know that you know who's not going to
screw you over but with the mechanic
does that's their business that's within
their power not within your power so he
says a few things here following this up
there that are really important to think
about and this is a good way to close
this off he says the business of the
wise and good man is to use appearances
these things in the world in conformity
with nature what does that mean so this
whole idea of harmony or conformity with
nature means living a fully human life a
life that is fully rational where these
things are not determining us but we are
actually determining ourselves which is
going to give us freedom otherwise we're
just caught up in this web of
determinism now he goes on and he says
some some other things that are really
good for putting this in perspective he
says as the moneychanger is not allowed
to reject Caesar's coin nor the seller
of herbs but if you show the coin
whether he chooses or not he must give
up what it's sold for the coin so it is
in the matter of the soul when the good
appears it immediately attracts to
itself the evil repels from itself but
the soul will never reject the manifest
appearance of the good any more than
persons will reject Caesar's
so what does that mean that means that
we need to pay attention to what really
is good we need to make sure that we've
got our basic ideas our fundamental
concepts worked out right so that
they're not going to lead us astray and
damage our ruling faculty and make us
more irrational because the ruling
faculty when it comes down to us is
really going to be a bunch of thoughts
and opinions and choices that we make
you know what are you saying here to
talk about the determinism part is that
if we've actually you know recognized
something as good even if we've miss
recognized it that's going to compel us
to seek it now we can we can see
something as good and we can have that
little voice saying no no it's not
really good for you and we have a choice
whether to listen to it or whether to go
along with our first impulse because we
do have a capacity to self-determine
here but once we've actually decided
which way we're going we're going to go
that way or this way so we need to be
very careful about what we actually give
our assent to what we actually say is
true or what we say is false what we
think is good what we think is bad and
for epictetus good and bad lie over here
they don't lie out there in the things
of the world except insofar as our use
and that's a matter of our choices our
use of them is good or bad but the
things themselves are neither good nor
bad
so we want to form proper understandings
of those and here's what I'm going to
close with forming those proper
understandings is not just a matter of
you know being rational taking in
information thinking about things it's
also got this this function of choosing
to it you can have information and not
use it and then the information isn't
any good to you visit you may as well
not have the information so what
actually is the evidence that somebody
truly is rational there
making the right kind of choices and
that contributes to or at least
maintains that our rationality